[Applause]
[Music]
it seems like every other week a new
video surfaces of police
killing kicking choking tasing or pepper
spraying an unarmed black person but
it's only because every other week
police actually kick kill choke tays or
pepper spray an unarmed black person and
if you're wondering how we got here i
think i can explain it in a segment we
call how did we get here
after every incident of police brutality
we have all these conversations about
racism qualified immunity police funding
resisting arrest and how ben crump gets
on the scene so quickly seriously is he
batman he might be batman but we rarely
examine how and why we got to a point
where
cops can literally hand out death
sentences to people who haven't harmed a
single soul but if we're going to talk
about how we got here we should begin by
defining where here is if we're talking
about cops killing unarmed black people
then here is on the side of the road
with a police officer's gun in your face
over a missing license plate here is
getting pepper sprayed in your car over
a temporary tag here is a routine
traffic stop because since 2015 that's
where one quarter of the killings of
unarmed black people have occurred and
another 15 percent occurred when police
were investigating misdemeanors or no
crime at all see cops don't injure or
kill black people during traffic stops
at higher rates than whites they just
pull over black drivers more often and
because they stop more black drivers
they just kill more black drivers
because here's the thing no one ever
says out loud law enforcement officers
kill more unarmed black people because
policing in america is more about debt
collection than enforcing the law
according to the stanford open policing
project black drivers are more likely
than white drivers to be pulled over
twice as likely to be searched and three
times more likely to experience the use
of force but here's the crazy part white
people are more likely to have something
illegal in their car and when i say
something illegal i don't mean a bootleg
dave matthews cd i mean drugs now you
might be thinking how do we know these
traffic stops are racially motivated
because according to a recent study at
night when it's harder for the cops to
see you they actually literally pull
over less black people and that's why
i'm moving to barrow alaska where it's
dark 24 hours a day
how cold is it there
oh no never mind i'm not but just as
crazy as the rate at which police pull
over black drivers are the reasons they
give for doing it take 20 year old dante
wright for instance who was killed
during a traffic stop this week
authorities claim police stopped him for
an expired tag and when they ran his
license they discovered that he had
outstanding warrants
the police officer who shot him kim
potter claims she accidentally killed
dante when she grabbed her gun instead
of her taser because he was resisting
now most people think that cop storier
is shadier than woody allen at a girl
scout meeting but maybe the more
important question is wait you had a gun
out because he owed money
so you stopped him because he hadn't
paid to renew his license tag and then
found out he had other outstanding debts
and your solution was to make him pay
more money how does that make sense or
how about quran nazario he's a second
lieutenant in the u.s army medical corps
who was pepper sprayed by police
officers during a traffic stop in
virginia and why was he stopped because
the cops couldn't see his license plate
it turns out that nazario's car was
brand new and he had a temporary tag
which because of the coronavirus you can
use for an extended period of time also
i should add
why the hell are we still talking about
license plates if i learn one more thing
about license plates this week i am
going to qualify to run a dmv
oh what a cute little dmv lady
but that's the part of police brutality
we never talk about the part where the
people who are supposed to protect and
serve us have essentially become armed
debt collectors why are the police
acting as debt collectors well because
in america we do this fun thing called
criminalizing poverty and here's how it
works
a city needs to make some money so they
attach a bunch of fines and fees to
petty that aren't even really crimes
like expired registration chipped paint
on your house or even in some towns
wearing saggy pants
police are encouraged to enforce these
crimes and of course they do so mostly
in poor black and brown communities
tickets get issued for small amounts 100
here 250 there but these are poor people
they can't pay they can't pay they're
issued a court date that means more fees
and fines a warrant is put out for their
arrest now they're a criminal you've
taken someone whose only problem was
that they were too broke to keep up with
the tax on their car and turn them into
a whole fugitive what an insane
overreaction to a small problem
that's like going on a mediocre first
date and at the end yelling i want a
divorce
this country literally makes it a crime
to be poor and to enforce that crime
they give officers guns why to defend
themselves if you think the police have
a dangerous job try being black
year in and year out unarmed black
people are killed by police at higher
rates than police are killed in the line
of duty
the police started out as slave patrols
but we aren't people's property anymore
we are and have always been human beings
with value the police are doing a bad
job because it is their job to do bad
the only people who think they're doing
a good job are the people who benefit
from the bad job they do it is a system
that makes money when we are arrested
and when they put us in jail and
i am begging you system get a different
income can you imagine what kind of
returns this country would get if they
invested in us
so please stop killing us over ina
nonsense like license plates what's the
worst that would happen if you did we
all drive around willy nilly with the
wrong stickers on our cars what would we
do with all those children whose mothers
and fathers weren't killed because of
broken taillights or suspended licenses
i'm sure we'd figure out something maybe
i'll ask batman
there are still a lot of people who
can't believe donald trump lost well
lots of republicans and there's a good
reason republicans can't believe trump
lost the election because they worked so
hard to rig it for him and they're
already trying to rig the next one in
fact just yesterday the florida
legislature passed a law to do just that
how did we end up in a democracy with so
many rigged elections let's find out in
a segment called how did we get here
voting is the cornerstone of any
democracy but currently in the u.s
361 bills have been introduced in 47
states to restrict access to voting
these days restricting voting is more
popular than tick tock or adding a why
to braden
these voter suppression bills are
designed specifically to curb the ways
that black people and other likely
democrats like city dwellers and working
class people vote for example right now
33 states are trying to limit early
voting and absentee voting both of which
are favored by voters on the left there
are also bills designed to restrict
mail-in voting and to make voting lines
longer by cutting back voting hours and
the number of voting machines and then
while you're waiting in that long ass
line they want to make it illegal for
anyone to hand you a snack that's not a
joke the georgia legislature recently
passed a bill that makes it a
misdemeanor to give food or water to
voters waiting in line no snacks that's
a real life bill that passed and i
already know one voter who's pissed
about it
all these laws put together are designed
to make voting so time consuming that
working-class voters can't afford to do
it but voting shouldn't be difficult and
time-consuming and bogged down by a
bunch of complex rules what is this a
vaccine appointment now republicans say
they're passing all these laws because
they're concerned about voter fraud but
voter fraud is a fake problems that
republicans made up you know how i know
because republicans can't find any the
republicans filed 50 court cases arguing
that voter fraud cost trump the election
and lost all of them trump lost 50 court
cases that man has more l's than
laverne's wardrobe
republicans are out here looking for
voter fraud like some of you are looking
for a single man with a bed frame honey
it don't exist just accept it so why is
it that with zero evidence of voter
fraud republicans are trying so hard to
stop black people from voting
because it's a time-honored american
tradition let's roll it all the way back
oh yeah it's time for your favorite part
of this comedy show history class
[ __ ] i have 150 years to cover so
keep up
in 1870 the 15th amendment gave black
men the right to vote and right after
that black voter registration soared in
some places it was 90 percent so white
people were like what have we done and
they invented jim crow laws these laws
kept black people from voting until 1965
when civil rights activists got the
voting rights act passed
it had a clause called section 5 that
listed the places that had historically
stopped black people from voting and
said that before those places could make
any new voting laws they had to get
approval from congress so congress could
make sure their new voting laws weren't
as racist as their old ones because a
place with a history of making racist
voting laws can't be trusted to make
voting laws just like your friend with
the t-shirt that says it's wine 30
cannot be trusted to be the designated
driver and section 5 worked finally
voting was kind of fair yay but then in
2012 two things happen the first is this
the second is that for the first time
ever black people voted at a higher rate
than white people and that's when the
modern voter suppression craze really
started all of a sudden republicans were
like voting is rigged like when a kid
loses a dodgeball and is like uh i think
the ball is broken so that year in a
case called shelby versus holder the
supreme court struck down section 5 on
the grounds that we didn't need it
anymore because get this racism was over
because you know if you elect one black
president and 44 white ones that means
racism is fixed just like if you flip a
coin 50 times and i guess right one time
i'm psychic
since that ruling at least 1688
counties have closed polling places and
every single one of those poll closings
would have been covered under section 5.
non-white precincts now have fewer
voting machines and longer lines they
made it illegal for black organizations
to register people to vote and they
purged voter rolls
the only way they could have made it
harder for black people to vote is if
when you registered they made you name
three beatles songs
hey jude and uh
i'll just see myself out
all this voter suppression was super
successful so successful that in 2016
this happened
but then covet happened and suddenly
people were working to ensure everyone
could vote safely so in the last
election people used early voting
absentee voting and mail-in voting more
than ever before and dropbox has got
more love than they did when blockbuster
was open which is why in the 2020
election we had the highest voter
turnout in a century
and which is why all of a sudden
republicans started freaking out about
voter fraud again because as we've
learned when there's high voter turnout
racists respond by trying to keep black
people from voting this is just history
repeating itself just like it always has
so that's how we got here to 361 bills
across the country that are designed to
fight voter fraud but you and i won't
fall for that because you and i both
know that voter fraud is a myth just
like that single man with a bed frame
it's may and news outlets are still
reporting news stories of people being
arrested for participating in the
january 6th attack on the capitol and
law enforcement has had some help in the
form of one of my favorite investigative
bodies america's ex-girlfriends
catfishes and bumble [ __ ] that's
right women have been turning in their
exes and catfishing and screenshotting
men who have bragged on dating apps and
social media about their role in the
january 6th riots white women using
their super power of tattling for good
you love to see it but as tickled as i
am about this sisters are doing it for
themselves approach to counterterrorism
i have to ask
how did we end up with this many people
feeling so comfortable committing an act
of terrorism in broad daylight and then
bragging about it let's find out in a
segment called how did we get here
the largest organized group at the
capitol riot on january 6th was a group
called the proud boys which sounds like
a brand of underpants for boys who have
just been potty trained but it's not
it's actually the name of a large white
supremacist movement in fact it's one of
many white supremacist groups who
participated in the riots that day these
groups organized the january 6th attack
openly online and two of their leaders
were these two guys joseph biggs and
ethan nordin biggs and nordine have both
been really lucky when it comes to not
getting arrested for crimes they
committed right in front of police in
2016 biggs beat up a protester at the
republican national convention but
police only charged the man he beat up
not biggs does that sound suspicious it
should because the police actually ended
up settling a civil case for falsifying
their own documents to make them more
sympathetic to biggs
but of course they were sympathetic to
biggs what would the police look like
arresting him for beating up a protester
it's literally their favorite thing to
do
biggs's friend nordim also punched a
protester in oregon the man he punched
was arrested and nor dean wasn't
the whole thing was caught on video and
the proud boy successfully used that
video as a recruiting tool online
these two prolific punchers brought a
hundred of their closest friends to dc
on january 6th to storm the capitol
thinking for good reason they could get
away with it it would be like if every
time you shoplifted you got a little
kiss on the forehead you'd think i can't
wait to shoplift some more
many right-wing extremist groups
participated that day they planned the
whole thing openly online and they
posted videos of themselves storming the
capital so why did they get the idea
this was an acceptable thing to do it's
simple because the federal government
stopped tracking domestic terrorism a
decade ago and that has allowed white
supremacist domestic terrorist groups to
flourish unchecked now i know that
sounds like a liberal rumor like j-lo
and ben getting back together but it's
actually a fact like j-lo and puffy
getting back together so
how did we get the fair i'm so glad you
asked
in 1995 timothy mcveigh carried out the
oklahoma city bombing the deadliest
domestic terrorist attack in u.s history
after that the feds cracked down on
domestic terrorism and it worked in the
1990s the number of domestic terrorist
attacks diminished
if only they could have done a similar
crackdown on frosted tips
two little cuties anyway it stayed that
way until 2009 when right-wing domestic
terrorism started to go up again can you
guess why honestly if you've been
watching the show you should be able to
guess why
that's right we elected a black
president white people lost their whole
dang minds and white supremacist groups
suddenly saw an uptick in membership
in 2009 the department of homeland
security produced a report warning about
the rise in right-wing domestic
terrorism now i've never understood why
whenever people are talking about white
supremacists republicans insist on
raising their hands and going they're
talking about us
talk about telling on yourself sweetie
nobody said your name but you
anyway fox news and republicans made a
huge stink about how an attack on
domestic terrorists was actually an
attack on them and then something crazy
happened the obama administration caved
to them they buried the report and
disbanded the unit that tracked
right-wing domestic terrorists obama
baby i love you but you really
oh what's that oh he can't hear me
because he's recording a podcast with
bruce springsteen
good for him
ever since then the number of right-wing
terrorist attacks has grown peaking in
2020 why 2020 because at this point not
only was trump fanning the flames of
white nationalism on camera he also
started helping them out behind the
scenes that's right you know it's not a
story about something bad happening in
america unless trump shows up to make it
worse
in 2020 trump's campaign message was
that the left was a threat to america so
he ordered the justice department to
find some left-wing terrorists
federal agents were shifted away from
right-wing targets and pressured to
uncover a left-wing extremist conspiracy
that did not exist of course it didn't
you think the left is capable of pulling
off a conspiracy we can barely pull off
an election
trump's department of homeland security
denied requests for funding to search
for warnings of extremism online pretty
embarrassing choice considering a bunch
of extremists tried to overthrow the
government and they planned it online
they couldn't spot it but i did and i'm
just a lady with a twitter account and
spotty spectrum wi-fi
and that's how we got here law
enforcement ignored the individual
threats right in front of their faces
missed the last decade of a rising trend
simply because republicans told them to
and then they literally looked the other
way while criminals walked past them in
broad daylight like every police cat in
every cartoon about a criminal mouse
and that's how we got here with our best
tool against domestic terrorism being
america's brave ex-girlfriends
well thank you for your service ladies
keep up the good work because nobody
else is doing it in the last year
there's been one discussion in congress
on weight raising the minimum wage and
it only lasted two hours and seven
minutes meanwhile there have been 14
hours of congressional testimony on
cancel culture which doesn't include the
time this idiot spent reading a
children's book
i do not like green eggs and ham i do
not like them sam i am
but to be fair kevin mccarthy is only
the second most powerful man in congress
now if you're wondering how we got here
maybe i can help in a segment called how
did we get here
when politicians get riled up about
something seemingly small like dr
seuss's family pulling his racist books
from shelves there's a name for it it's
called the culture wars a culture war is
a conflict between groups struggling for
dominance of their values beliefs and
practices basically when a politician
can't win by making a logical political
argument they resort to a culture war
like instead of coming up with a good
immigration policy they just yell about
how immigrants are going to steal your
jobs or instead of finding a bipartisan
solution to climate change they tell you
joe biden is going to steal your
hamburgers now that's a real example
republican congresswoman lauren bobert
tweeted it followed by why doesn't joe
stay out of my kitchen and frankly he
should because her kitchen is full of
guns
she said why doesn't joe stay out of my
kitchen and she's right he needs to stay
out of my kitchen until he learns how to
work a hot comb
if you're not old
and you're not black then don't you try
to understand that joke
here's another example this is rachel
levine she waited over a month to be
confirmed as assistant secretary of
health of course there was no rush we're
only in a global pandemic a lot of
republicans opposed levine's nomination
because let's check her qualifications
oh she's a pediatrician she graduated
from harvard she served as
pennsylvania's secretary of health so
she's literally done the job before
let's see if she was confirmed it would
make her the first openly transgender
federal official in history i found it i
found the reason it's because they're
terrible so terrible that kentucky
senator rand paul just kept repeating
the words genital mutilation over and
over again during levine's confirmation
hearing genital mutilation has been
nearly universally condemned genital
mutilation has been condemned by the who
the united nations children's fund the
united nations population fund
according to the who
genital mutilation is recognized
internationally as a violation of human
rights
genital mutilation is considered
particularly egregious because as the wh
notes it is nearly always carried out on
minors
that man is not just terrible he's
raisins in the potato salad terrible and
if that clip didn't make any sense
that's the entire purpose of a culture
war it's not supposed to make any sense
it's supposed to scare people away from
wanting change it's one of the oldest
tricks in the book not green eggs and
ham i'm talking about the book that
convinces people that anti-racists are
going to turn the tables and enslave
white people or that saying black lives
matter means you're anti-cop or that gay
people are going to steal your children
and raise them though frankly you should
be so lucky and if you think a war on
culture is some kind of exaggerated
metaphor it's not the ideas that
conservatives sling around in the
culture wars are dangerous and they cost
people's lives it's not a coincidence
that the fir that the worst year for
violence against transgender and gender
non-conforming people was 2020 when the
trump administration reversed laws that
protected transgender americans and it's
not a coincidence that anti-asian hate
crimes rose 150
last year after the president publicly
demonized asian people now this is the
part of the segment where we usually
reach back and find an obscure example
from history but not today today we only
have to reach back to 2020 when old rand
genital mutilation paul blocked a bill
that would make lynching a federal crime
no one could understand why rand paul
wouldn't want to pass a law called the
emmett till anti-lynching act but paul
didn't have to explain himself because
he waited until everyone was distracted
on the day of george floyd's funeral who
blocks an anti-lynching bill during a
funeral that is some next level evil
joffrey baranthian heard that and was
like too far
okay so here's the obscure part in 1918
congressman leonidas dyer also
introduced a bill to make lynchings a
federal crime but it was defeated
because and this was the literal reason
they wrote down on paper they needed a
tool to stop black men from raping white
women can you imagine putting something
that awful in writing i won't even put
gossip in a text
i put it in a voice memo
during the next year in the red summer
of 1919 lynchings exploded then in the
1920s the naacp begged congress to pass
an anti-lynching bill they even financed
a study that proved
that black men weren't going around
attacking cairns black men were just
doing what black men in the 1920s did
minding their own dang business and
making finger waves look good but the
bill failed and so has every
anti-lynching bill from the 1920s until
now to this day there has never been a
law against lynching in the united
states this law is more overdue than a
woman who is 15 months pregnant and even
she would be like forget me just pass
the bill
now you might be wondering if there
could be a reason for this besides
racism well let me ask you this do you
think there has never been a transgender
person qualified to work in government
in the history of this country do you
think it's a coincidence that congress
is 77 percent white and that set that
it's also 73 male or that 83 percent of
the federal judiciary is white this
isn't racism it's beyond racism this is
white supremacy because the purpose of a
culture war is to make sure people are
afraid of change
and resisting change means maintaining
power and that's why they're fighting to
keep racist children's books and
confederate statues and that's why
they'd rather talk about cancel culture
than domestic terrorism because culture
wars and white supremacy go together
like well green eggs and ham and i do
not like them sam i am this has been how
did we get here there's been a phrase
that news organizations have been
throwing around a lot critical race
theory everyone is saying it but no one
seems to be able to agree on what it is
now how do we get to a point where
everyone is saying a phrase they can't
even define
let's find out in a segment called how
did we get here
in the past few weeks several state
legislatures have introduced bills
banning critical race theory they've
done it in georgia tennessee florida
mississippi oklahoma and a bunch of
other states where you can buy
confederate flags at gas stations but
the thing is while some americans are
furious about critical race theory a lot
of people don't even know what it is and
i don't blame them critical race theory
sounds like the subtitle of a book
called mario kart for dummies first i'm
going to pick up speed then i'm going to
throw some nana's then i'm going to get
some coins and that is my critical race
theory now in order to talk about
critical race theory we're going to
start with something called the 1619
project the 1619 project is an
extraordinary pulitzer prize winning
work of journalism conceived of by a
reporter named nicole hannah jones it
was released to commemorate the 400th
anniversary of the arrival of enslaved
africans in the colonies that would
become america that's right the first
anniversary is paper the fifth is wood
and the 400th is well-researched and
award-winning journalism get to work
husbands
one of the reasons the 1619 project has
been so controversial is that it
proposes that we should talk a lot more
about the consequences of slavery and
the contributions of black people when
we talk about the foundations of our
country which of course means
acknowledging that racism permeates our
history because the fact is right now
kids aren't learning the realities of
our history in 2018 only eight percent
of u.s high school seniors could
identify slavery as the central cause of
the civil war and that is horrifying
that's like only eight percent of kids
knowing you can make a volcano with
mentos and diet coke they're both basic
facts now the good news is that about
two-thirds of students do seem to know
that the emancipation proclamation freed
the slaves except and here's the thing
it absolutely did not do that that
required a whole constitutional
amendment which wasn't even ratified
till after abraham lincoln died
in a horrible boating accident
all the 1619 project was supposed to do
is help teach students about the role
slavery has played in american history
now some people claim that's rewriting
history and maybe it is but shouldn't we
revise things when we get better
information we used to prescribe cocaine
for two things now we know better and
it's mostly used so that former lacrosse
players can talk about crypto for seven
hours straight yeah you gotta have
bitcoin bro
the point is as we learn more of course
we should adjust what we're teaching in
some parts of the country if students
learn black history at all they learned
that
most masters treated their slaves kindly
or slaves were given the opportunity to
become christians instead of remaining
heathen or that slaves got to eat all
the barbecue pringles they wanted
all of those things are equal parts
[ __ ] but the first two are actual
quotes from a textbook that was used in
south carolina for 130 years which is
probably why their current senator
thinks that racism doesn't exist he
thinks it disappeared right around when
daniel boone killed all the dinosaurs
now this would be a great time for me to
tell you what we need to do to improve
our national history curriculum but
here's the thing we don't have a
national history curriculum
every state sets its own teaching
standards think of school curriculums
like state mottos every state has a
different one and some of them are
batshit crazy oregon's state motto is
she flies with her own wings
that's not a motto that's a tagline for
a cicada biopic
the fact is most states don't mandate a
specific amount of black history at all
which is why most white people only know
about harriet tubman martin luther king
and barack obama even worse 20 of them
think that that's destiny's child
if only there were some kind of say
prize-winning black history curriculum
developed by some of the greatest
scholars in the country i'm sure that
americans would welcome it with open
arms and by arms i mean guns because it
turns out there are a lot of white
people who really don't want to learn
the truth about america and that finally
brings us back to critical race theory
which is just a way of examining society
and history without pretending that
racism doesn't exist racism is part of
our past and our present it's been with
us for 400 years you can't squash it
into two sentences in a textbook between
the civil war and the roaring twenties
you shouldn't fix history to make you
feel better learning about slavery feels
awful too bad try living with its
repercussions while white people tell
you there weren't any also it should
make you feel bad it should make you
feel so bad that you make sure nothing
like it ever happens again
critical race theory gives us the tools
to examine our history in an open and
honest way and to fix the parts of our
educational system that aren't doing
that but my theory is that some white
people don't want to change our
education system because it benefits
them they literally were able to become
congressmen and senators and people who
make laws about american history without
actually knowing american history or
maybe they're afraid that we might start
treating white people like white people
treat us
maybe they don't even know they've been
learning the white version of history
this whole time anyway that's my theory
and if it's not accurate my theory about
race will fall apart as soon as someone
critically examines it if only there was
a way to do that but i guess that's how
we got here
[Music]
you